The Joe Rogan Experience but that's
Kiana like Keanu bring like that's not
just general that's Keanu Keanu loves
cars he loves bikes he loves the
discipline of it he loves like that's
why he's got Arch motorcycles right if
you ever get a chance you should check
that shop out it's the most pristine I'm
sure I can't [__] with motorcycles I'm
scared of them yeah but to build just to
watch how he's got all the water Cutters
there it's very it's a very artistic oh
the bikes are incredible they're great
but he brings that to every like he just
he's very
not compulsive he's very uh he loves
yeah he loves the art of it he's
fascinated by like who makes this cup
Joe like how do you like he everything
he'll he just Fascinate over he wants a
story on it he's one of the most curious
most
um I guess curious artistically like how
things are done who people are he's just
got a genuine curiosity and love for
things he's a very unique guy and I
think so I've never met him but it just
every interview you see with him every
movie he's a very unusual person yeah
and he's got you know I think I think
anybody really artistic or at least the
really I think artistic people that I've
met they maintain that little bit of and
I mean this in in the best of ways a
little bit of of childness Wonder
um there's still kids a little bit like
I I could talk to you all day about like
archery I could talk to you all day
about Marshall I talked to you all day
about motorcycle I could talk to you all
day about movies and I think that's you
got to have that you need that little
inspiration I think you need that little
bit of of Wonder one wonderlust into
into certain things and I think he still
got that like he he will still he'll see
a sequence we'll come in with the numb
chucks and do something and he'll start
giggling he's like you want me to do
that he's like okay that's pretty cool
and he just goes from totally serious
guy to okay now how do I learn how to
know and he just everything you need to
know about an object he wants to know
about num checks he just throws himself
into it so how much time did he have to
train martial arts before John Wick won
oh God it wasn't that
he was coming out of a couple films so
he hadn't been
um like he wasn't in fight shape that
was so you know how you know it's just
like you can't just jump back in so we
gave him like I think three to five
weeks with some of the trainers we found
to get into shape to get into shape
you know cut weight got himself back in
stretched you know kind of got back into
where he was on The Matrix
and then we stuck him with the the fight
teams and the stunt guys
I think we had them within three months
that was probably the shortest one we
did that was about three months to get
him into that shape and teach him all
the you know the Aikido stuff and the
Aki Jitsu well you need so there's so
much going on those movies physically
that you need to be proficient in yeah
the gun stuff the the throws Jiu Jitsu
striking everything the Jiu Jitsu is the
new thing for him probably not the most
physically demanding but you know how it
is we used to using your hands and feet
I mean I'm sure you remember the first
time you transitioned Jitsu it's like it
looks easy but yeah
completely it's an eye opener yeah it
really is and only even recently for me
I'm starting to feel like oh I can move
I like it feels just as good to be on my
back as my butt is like you know but I
think we took a lot of inspiration from
dance like you know
most of what we do is dance they're
based on Dance drills they're not based
on martial art drills they look like
martial arts we kick punch but we don't
train the actors in tie pads or Focus
mitts or heavy bag we'll do maybe a
little that for impact stuff but it's
mostly about memory because if a guy can
punch a kick that's great but if you
can't remember five moves
you're not much good right and it's more
you know martial arts is Action Reaction
or causing the guy to be off balance all
our guys are trying to to keep him on
balance to make it look crazy but they
gotta dance with them so it's about that
metronome
keeping the beat going so when we
trained him
um he hadn't been trained that way
before it was more like memorizing
memorizing uh you know a few moves
hitting some kind of sequence but we
realized we had no money and we had no
time and every time we do punches and
kicks you've seen most movies right like
they're on you right over my shoulder
then you know you take the hit and it
goes over your shoulder so I can sell
the hit so you're always doing these
reverses so if I do a big wide shot
profile you throw in a nice roundhouse
kick I gotta cut somewhere to show the
impact unless you're really kicking me
which not advisable most of the time so
all every time the more punching and
kicking striking you do or if piano's
not doing the motion I gotta cut more
and every time I cut it's a setup it's
just time consuming not that it's bad or
good it's just time consuming we knew we
weren't going to have that so we're like
[__] what do we do okay we're just gonna
grab people we're just gonna make it all
grappling and like is that gonna look
you know you remember it's all during
the born so everything's gonna look very
slow
you know compared to what it was but
we're just we're gonna do all great
we're gonna do Aikido akijitsu and
Jiu-Jitsu that's it that's all you get
and if you get a punch it'll be a
contact hit that's all we're gonna do no
punches no kicks no nothing and we'll do
it all in one take and we're all like uh
yeah sounds good
um no one no yeah we thought it was a
complete disaster after the first two
days of shooting the fight scenes we're
like this is gonna suck we're [__]
um why'd you think that though I think
it was everyone's mindset like we did it
out of necessity and we thought it was
cool but like you'd see people that
where's the like you know some sometimes
people look at well he's doing the same
throw over it I mean epon cyanogi looks
the same but for us the different grips
the different throws it all looks
different to me like I'm a throw you
know I love Judo porn I I could watch a
million different throws it's awesome
um for some people it all looks the same
they want to see the cool jump spin hook
kick or something like that
um but then we put in the close quarter
stuff and when you're seeing it remember
we don't have the muzzle flashes on we
don't have the blood splatters right so
you're just kind of seeing you know it
looks like they're dancing right and
then you put in the sound effects and
you put in the muzzle and then you put
in the [__] reload and like now it's
making sense so what do you when when
he's shooting in the actual filming is
he just pulling the trigger and it's
just going click well see that's the
thing you have dummy rounds when you
when you most movies you always see A to
B cutting right I'm on you you're the
guy like guns in the camera you fire the
blank most Firearms up until very
recently fire blanks and for the people
out there a blank is around without the
actual bullet the lead piece it hits but
a blank still has a gun powder charge in
it say maybe a you know even if it's
only 50 grams of black powder but at a
range of 10 to 15 feet that'll still
that can kill you yeah concussive force
that's and you hear about all the
accidents that have happened with blanks
over the years like you can't put a
blank under your head and pull the
trigger yeah right so we want to do all
this close quarter shooting like we
wanted to put the muzzle and do all this
stuff close quarter contact stuff so we
you know we went to our VFX guys and the
trick is not so much the muzzle flask
it's the lighting interaction especially
at night and it's cycling the automatic
yeah getting it in and having the casing
ejection all do but it can add up with
visual effects costs so we went and we
found um the armors and you know through
Taran and the other the technologies
that we found through the armors we made
a plug gun a plug gun is a gun that has
a almost a steel rod inside the barrel
and it kicks the gas a different way so
we still have an ejection but nothing no
energy no flash no padding and wadding
comes out the barrel like you know you
couldn't put a live round in it if you
tried so is it a lower round a lower
level
in England they use some that are like
almost air contained they can do it in
us it's a very very small charge of of
black powder so it's a very very we call
them plug guns they're very very limited
in in the drainage so it's just enough
to cycle around just enough to cycle it
yep nothing yeah exact thing but nothing
comes out the barrel so all that stuff
that you see the blood splash better
that's all CGI the blood is all CG
there's one or two instances where it's
not but most of the blood is the blood's
so good nowadays digitally that it saves
so much time because we don't have to
change the word over get it I mean like
you know you seem like a Tarantino like
in Django Tarantino still uses old
school blood packs which I you know I'm
old school I [__] love that I think
it's amazing but with just the time and
you know you like you see a John Wick
movie it's like you know the reset on 20
stunt guys taking hits a one day it'd be
a three hour reset to change the
Wardrobe right and head shots you'd have
to put a special head pack on with a wig
and all that stuff so we do we do the
the blood hits digitally the muzzle
flashes we actually shoot against a
green screen and we'll call them
elements and then we'll plug actual
muzzle flashes back into the movie later
on so they're not digital per se but
they are Compton or in a composition and
that's how we get the cool lighting
effect and keep the cool muzzle flashes
how long did it take you to film that
red circle bar scene I think less than
four days really yeah we went really
fast and Keanu is he had the flu he had
like 103 degree fever he was going down
it was it was a rough day it was
freezing cold New York he had the flu
a super high temperature and we're just
flying through it like literally two
three takes move on two three filming it
with the flu wow yeah he's a trooper man
that's incredible yeah he's a tough
[__] a lot of actors have a [__]
earache to call it quits for the day uh
yeah yeah no comment no comment but like
most of the people we work with are they
get it and we try to be smart too look
if we if there's another way if we could
have shut down and let them we just it
was like one of those we either gotta
stop or we don't but we don't get one
shot and you couldn't count as that guy
too you can't you can't make him where
did you film that I was on New York City
but the the red circle it was in this
little it was up in the Theater District
I forget the name of it it was a
shutdown little Club
that we just kind of opened back up and
put on put our own their own lighting
rig in there and just kind of lit it up
I mean if you had seen it in the daytime
it was all like that [__] brown leather
it looked like you're walking into a
like uh you know big boys or something
it looked really bad that gives credit
to John sella the cinema tiger on the
first one we went in
put our lighting grid up flashed a lot
of big screen neon lights put the extras
in funny colors and you know we ran out
of money so we're like we didn't we
didn't know how to put the the bad guys
in something so we're like okay what
would Star Trek do in Star Trek we
always call them the red shirts you know
the guys in Star Trek that right always
getting killed you have to do was right
there Kirk was transporting down to the
planet with the Redshirt guy and that
guy was gone so he put all our bad guys
in the red shirts they were just gonna
kill them all I think we had a deal
there's a local like one of the Garment
District things you could I think we got
all those red shirts for like 10 bucks
it was like a whole deal so he's got all
the stunt guys red shirts but yeah we
did it on this shitty little Club in
like four days five uh maybe four and a
half days something like that